[Musique]
il est beau c'est cher comment il
s'appelle simplement qu'elle agit là il
a huit mois des beaux seins c'est quoi
comme race
alors là c'est bon
des données
[Musique]
toutes deux étaient pas mal non
elle voulait 00 10
pour cela rendue tous saluent des prises
nous sommes tout denier de terre
inconnue ce ne soit pas mais quand au
sommet nous avons tout heureux d assez
fou
beauté sur la joue nous sommes deux
soeurs
sous les yeux de g
face à la virémie face aux san remo et
bravi tous les carrefours et
rémy 5 ça s'arrête au nous sommes
toujours très léger
ascendant de l'amour et sur les convainc
les douze bon sauvage de passion
toutes deux étapes et un horizon nous
avons tout eu lui lave délicat artiste
passionné musiciens acrobates cherchant
tan cheng bock un idéal à escoussens
d'efforts nous sommes deux soeurs
jumelles
sous le signe était chez moi
penny pas sur un seul réseau
[Musique]
iago
oh
l'art de l'anti jeu
jusqu'ici de leçons de ce fait
j'en ai jusque là la province m'ennuie
je me dis pas présent
a paris je n'en signerai pas toute ma
vie déjà non
dis moi aussi je tenterais ma chance
pourquoi passer mon temps à enseigner
débat
alors que j'ai envie d'aller à l'opéra
où seuls deux heures du mat
souligne le dg mois
la durée
allez
ça y est
[ __ ]
alors
me lambert
alors d'habitants qu'on sache soit parce
que là ça lâche mort
on a ramassé la tête accusés trop
proches ont dit d'accord puisque c'est
là où sedan selon vous déshabiller comme
on est un peu plus vite
c'est beau c'est qu'on perd c'est
beaucoup mieux que catherine deneuve
françoise a rien à voir
quand je pense que les gens sortent de
la gueule dans ces deux fois les filles
sous le signe des gémeaux oh là là bas
ap
[Musique]
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu